this is a virtual gavel and I gabble a
meeting of Health and Human Services
oversight committee for Friday January
26 there are two car car crashes in
process on i93 so some of our members
may be late I can't speak for the rest
of them wish to thank the honorable Lucy
Weber um probably chair at one point of
this group I was I think I think I was
of us have
been I'm the kid uh so uh representative
Weber will be acting as
Clerk and it's it gives five minutes for
a roll call of who is here I think we
can do it in 30 seconds at most I'm
stretching while she gets her pen and
paper ready and if there's no chair uh
no seats you can fill in down the end
here but you belong here so you don't
have to do that good morning oh we're
find
yeah
far
store but I realize I can't so drag
chairs from anywhere and spill over into
the ends and let's get cozy um approval
of the draft minutes from the
December uh regular meeting we cannot do
because we lack a quorum next item uh
DHHS Commissioners update and it gives
it commissioner singular but we have so
many Comm Commissioners Deputy
Commissioners assistant Commissioners
wish good morning feel so far
away good morning Lori Weaver
commissioner Health and Human Services
for the record and I have with me a
guest today uh new employee of our H
Hamet Hospital our new chief executive
officer of Hamet Hospital Justin luer
we've asked for could you give us the
name again
please uh Justin luer l o s
r thank you I'm I'm substituting and I
have arus so
Jos so in terms of her uh commissioner's
update we thought it would be um helpful
for Justin to give um talk a little bit
about himself and where he's been and
some of the goals and what the last two
weeks have been like since his first day
Tuesday good morning thank you for
having me uh so my name is Justin lucer
uh I've worked in Behavioral Health in
the state of New Hampshire for the
better part of uh 18 years I took a
quick break to put on a Massachusetts
for a little bit of a bigger role tenant
but most of my career has been with uh
HCA uh and HCA in New Hampshire so
Portsmouth Hospital uh Parkland Medical
Center and frisbee Memorial Hospital uh
during my time with HCA I oversaw all
Behavioral Health
Services uh and HCA had worked very very
closely with state to increase our
services inclusive of more involuntary
beds uh a large expansion of outpatient
programs and an expansion of inpatient
beds from uh 21 to 71 uh during my 10
years
there it's very re rewarding to work for
HCA uh in New Hampshire because they had
a commitment to expanding Behavioral
Health Services uh but as I uh got more
exposure to working with the state uh to
look at increasing Services uh for
Behavioral help I found a a passion uh
that that's where I sort of wanted to be
uh and when the Hamstead position opened
up I felt like that would be a good fit
uh to help to continue execute uh
hamad's mission to become a center of
excellence for children in the state of
New
Hampshire the last two weeks have been
uh very busy a lot of meetings over at
Hamstead meeting a lot of people uh I
started prior to my first day reaching
out to the Community Mental Health
Centers the executive directors to start
setting up some meetings uh so really
the beginning goal is to bring all the
stakeholders
together uh to build support for
Hamstead but also to continue uh the
state's mission to to make Hamstead a
safe place to be for
kids uh I had a a meeting with uh Jeff
fler at dcyf to kind of discuss and
build some of those stakeholder
relationships but day-to-day uh I think
Hamstead is certainly moving in the
right direction uh Melissa St Seer Who
is the interm CEO really started a
course for Hamstead uh you know to
function as
a moving towards that Center of
Excellence so safety huddles are in
place you know we meet every morning
with directors and managers to ensure
any incidents the prior nights uh are
followed by a root cause analysis if
there was an incident uh but I believe
that we're really moving in the right
direction I will say that uh I've been
to many hospitals in my career um
and one thing that certainly stands out
uh about Hamstead is almost all of the
staff all of the staff that I've met so
far committed uh to the work they do
there and you don't see that at every
hospital uh that you go to um but I was
fortunate to meet with all the
department heads over there uh and
everyone is open to change and to sort
of executing towards our goal to be able
to serve uh the Youth of New Hampshire
my largest uh one of the issues that's
most important to me that that uh
continues to be important to me is
decreasing emergency room wait times uh
for anyone struggling with Behavioral
Health I think it's a tragedy Nationwide
that people have to wait days or weeks
to to seek care uh and certainly we are
on the move to decrease that for kids uh
overall I think uh within the next
couple years like to move to a direct
admission uh process so we can
completely avoid
emergency rooms within the state and get
immediately you're in an excellent
neighborhood by the
way yes very beautiful we love our
neighbors too thank you I'm 300 yards
south of the
facility um question perhaps for the
commissioner uh the relationship of um
the new CEO to the staff that is under
contract that may be up for Renewal what
relationship so Justin and his role as
CEO oversees all all contracts within
the facility including that particular
contract we have with with wellpath so
Justin will as intended when we set up
the structure represent the state and
the state's intended course and vision
and where we're going and then hold the
vendor to that execution of that
particular contract and that Vision so
he does day-to-day engagement and
day-to-day oversight um as well as um
trying to create a sense of a culture of
one team so that we don't have this
split of US versus them uh in the
facility trying to bring it together as
one uh Hospital serving uh kids when is
the current contract up the current
contract will be up July one of this
year uh we had an RFP that is currently
still out with responses due in a couple
of weeks and our team including Justin
will be a part of the selection team and
reviewing all of the proposals and
making a selection so that we can have a
transfer happen a transition if there is
one uh if there's a different vendor
selected to have a transition take place
this summer without mentioning their
names uh you've received how many rfps
to
date request for proposal I mean bids on
the job um yeah because it's an act of
procurement I really can't really say I
can tell you that I've had I have had uh
more than three uh vendors in the region
Express an interest in bidding but there
are bids for it from others than the
present group don't think I can say that
yet because I'm an actor procurement
okay they're not due till February 8th
so I don't know who's actually bid yet
thank you Marissa hen thank you Marissa
H uh maybe next meeting we can know more
um Mr Lua um has the number of incidents
requiring emergency response uh gone
down uh
recently uh yes so it is not a pattern
or Trend yet but we have seen a decrease
from quarter to quarter and quarter four
was the least amount of seclusion and
restraint uh issues for children uh and
and a drop in EMS 911 calls
substantially um I would like to say
that we've done all that work in two
weeks uh but that would be naive so we
are starting on a good Trend uh which
I'm happy to report out in the future uh
and hopefully we see this as um not just
a blank but a real Trend towards uh
stability I'm sure the interface between
the emergency responders whether they're
EMTs or uh law enforcement and the staff
um the interface there is always
something that we strive for excellence
in yes I think day-to-day patient facing
staff and EMS responders have a really
cordial good working relationship uh
we're certainly grateful for those to
have those resources if an incident
arises however part of decreasing those
incidents is to increase
uh you know staff skill uh with you know
increased training so we have rolled out
CPI for all of our an enhanced CPI which
is seclusion restraint deescalation for
patients uh for all staff uh with the
eye of like how do we contain the
patient millu before it gets to an
incident that occurs I think that's
really the the the Crux of maintaining a
safe environment is being able to
understand
um the issues that are facing you dayto
day and getting in front of them before
they get to a point of escalation self
harm or harm to
others Senator welcome back thank
you welcome
to Amstead Mr luer um am I Mis
remembering that the RFP was originally
issued in the spring and then called
back to talk to
other kinds of other providers could you
talk a little bit
about maybe there anything you can tell
us if I'm not
misremembering sure when we originally
bought Hamstead we had a expectation
that we would have the current vendor in
that role that was the sole source Award
of that contract uh for that period of
time and that we would then go out to
our P I think what we didn't know then
that we did know uh further into it at
that point of the first procurement is
that um what we thought in terms of some
of the models that were going to be the
way that we would want it to work
weren't necessarily working so even
though we issued that RFP um we realized
that we had issued it almost prototype
of what it was before and that it wasn't
working and as we all know there's been
some things going on so we pulled that
back saying what what should the model
look like based off of what we know in
order to do that we pulled back and
engaged some folks that work in
psychiatric care for adolescence and
said you know looking at this model what
are your thoughts on it what would what
are your recom recommendations and
advice so we took all of that in and
November thank you so she's following
that I I just wanted to the people who
are standing for the for the people who
are really can't sit
please come and sit at the end of the
table you're not required to stand
through this whole thing it will you're
welcome it will not issue in a
diminution of your salary to what a
legislator
meets um Senator I see that as of today
on the website there are 11 children
waiting an emergency rooms for beds and
that Hamstead has 19 beds that are not
available because of
renovation um when is that going to be
finished and if they if it was finished
do you have the staff to operate those
beds right
now so we have two units that have drop
ceilings so essentially the drop
ceilings are you know you can push up
and sort of get up into the ceiling into
the wires not this one but uh that's not
an appropriate ceiling for a inpatient
psychiatric unit unless the ceilings
were above 10 ft High which they're not
so to redo that and decrease the
incidences so just to back up one second
so in terms of The Joint Commission you
can have drop ceilings as long as
they're Clips but kids are a little bit
more uh intuitive to know that those
clips can come out and be used to harm
themselves so one of our units so two
units have those drop ceilings one is
almost complete we anticipate that that
will be done at
project completion uh by the second week
of February we will then move into which
we just had a construction meeting
yesterday an immediate uh move to the
second unit where the construction will
start right then I can't give you a date
as to when that's completed because what
we have asked the contractor is to look
at a schedule that that's inclusive of
nights and weekends because I think you
know to your point we want to be able to
create access for everybody and if the
cost of that um is reasonable to have
that done days nights weekends we can
get that done within two weeks I will
say that today we were just talking
prior to the meeting starting uh that we
are at uh 51 Uh current patients which
is the highest that hamet's been in the
past two years when you look at our
available beds on at that hospital right
now minus the beds that are capped
because the units under construction
we're at 93% capacity so industry
standard on any inpatient mental health
unit is typically 80% and that's because
of issues like blocked beds gender
identity issues uh and we are over that
right now so again uh not a trend yet uh
but hopefully moving towards that Trend
can
I thank you if if this two week nights
and weekends bed comes in higher than
you have funding for does the department
with the department
consider coming to fiscal and asking to
transfer
funds uh I'll let the commissioner
answer but just as an aside we the
project that we looked at right now uh
is unbelievably reasonable in terms of
Hospital construction so two
units uh having the complete ceiling as
a hard toop uh was under I believe
$667,000 uh so substantial work so I
it's not in my purview to continue to go
back to the state and ask for more money
but when we look
at the discussion that we had in about
nights and weekends in construction is
looking at if we can minimize the time
that that unit's open does the the cost
or the return on that equal the spending
weekends would you like me to well that
confused me a little bit because are we
looking at dollars and cents or are we
right in terms of our we're not looking
at dollars and cents uh you know in
terms of the state we're looking at all
of our available beds and filling those
beds to the best of our capacity from a
staffing perspective uh there are a
couple positions that we'll need to fill
those are Le leadership position working
leadership positions on each unit uh and
I met with we met together yesterday
with wellpath to discuss posting
recruiting for those positions as well
um so I apologize for speaking in
dollars and sense but looking at sort of
the revenue uh that that could
potentially come in supplementing the
additional cost but but that is not the
focus of Hamstead is
revenue may I add something I mean we
would obviously support the facility
with whatever uh objective we were
trying to get to but I do just want to
point out that the children's weight
less has has vacillated greatly over the
last 60 days I mean at one point we were
almost at zero we're at one and then it
shot up and then it goes down so I think
you know we see Trends in different
times of the year of when services are
are um needed more than others but I
think what Justin you know speaking to
increase our capacity so when that does
vasil late and it's higher that we're
able to take those kids in um and then
obviously not have kids stay in longer
than they need to but be getting back
home or wherever it is that they're
going to be getting going to
Weber I'm not trying to put words in
representative Rosen malt's mouth but
her questions Senator Senator Senator I
my mind goes back to Fawn times in the
past
um but my her
questions sparked some of my own which
is as a follow-up to what she said you
mentioned several times with respect to
the work being on the nights and
weekends work and whether that was going
to be reasonable in terms of cost so I
never really heard an answer to her
question about if those costs are higher
than you feel that your current funds
can absorb are you willing to go to are
you planning or willing to go to fiscal
and ask for more funds or um how is that
determination going to be made because
it seems to me we've got a bunch of
things going on there's the the the how
fast can we get the construction done
issue there's the how fast can we staff
it up issue and I think that everybody
is very grateful that the capacity is
already trending in the right direction
they're just wondering Ways and Means of
how we get to getting those last two
units open we would explore all ways and
means to getting that open and come to
fiscal if it required us to do
so thank
you anyone else representative Merchant
thank you m chair and also thank you uh
for being
here this obviously has been very much
on the radar for legislative as well as
citizens of New
Hampshire going forward to show that
we're making prog ress towards the
success of defined
success what do you envision as far as
providing to this committee reports on
the updates if you will on how we're
doing um I hate to see it 12 months
later we had another report but
periodically I think early stage of the
process is help me understand what do
you envision being reporting frequency
as well as what should be in the
report so I think we should both answer
that I believe that Justin has um some
ideas about how he's going to be
reporting out on the quality and
improvements that he's making at
Hamstead I would just offer here as we
do with a lot of our other initiatives
or programs if you will the frequency
you know if we wanted to establish a
frequency to have Justin come back and
share that report we'd be more than
happy to do that I'll let him speak to
what he's looking at for metrics
or sure so what I'm used to looking at
metrics in patient Behavioral Health uh
some of that isn't there at ham yet but
we're putting that in place uh one of
the things that we're starting with is
for every unit typically we have the
same structure as any other Behavioral
Health Hospital which is a a program
director and a a nurse manager for each
unit uh so we're starting monthly
operating reports with each member of
those leaderships to report on sort of
the specifics to each unit uh and then
from a hospital overall perspective what
I'm looking at is sort of incidents of
seclusion restraint incidents of injury
average length of stay average daily
census uh and then also CMS has um hbips
quality measures uh that we're looking
at as well on top of those things what I
really feel are important are both
Employee
Engagement uh and patient satisfaction
our Employee Engagement survey uh
started a week before I came and is set
to wrap the third week of February so
we're out there sort of pushing
employees to take that and to give their
feedback back on safety and quality
concerns as well as working at Hamstead
uh and then in terms of patient
satisfaction our scores are very high uh
I just saw the reports yesterday that
came out um but I'm not quite sure of
our end size if that meets uh validity
at this point but we're looking at
through those things so I think for this
committee or any any Committee in terms
of transparency for
Hamstead we want to have a stable
average length of stay that doesn't the
the goal National goal for children
adolescence is 10 days we'd like to be
close to that we do have some
disposition issues uh for kids who end
up waiting a little bit longer but our
average daily census any blocked bed
issues uh things that we would report
out uh and then I think the overall um
real measure for Hamstead is looking at
the weight list and does it Trend down
and how quickly can we get those
patients in so we are every day taking a
good chunk out of that weight list
um during the height of kids in the Eds
um when I was at HCA we had about 36
kids in our Ed and those were just three
EDS across the state uh and now we're
trending I think I believe today is
14 um and it's been last week it was in
the single digits which is great
progress for the state but uh certainly
not where we want to be which is zero
weights
thank you for
that sometime in the next probably uh
month or so if we could find from you or
have from you a list of some of the
metrics that you want to measure and
then where we are today so as we go
forward we can measure progress towards
where we started so if you have some
metrics in mind which obviously sounds
like you do if you can share that with
the committee I don't think per se
having you come back periodically to but
if there's a report being provided to us
in a written format we can follow along
accordingly if we find something at that
point in time we could invite them
committee yeah Senator um two questions
one do you look at the average length of
stve for children on Medicaid versus
Commercial Insurance um or and is it
different and the second question is is
the prtf open yet and has that helped
with your
discharges yeah no we don't I don't
currently look at uh link to stay uh in
terms of payer mix um
about this is don't quote me on this but
we're roughly right around 70 80%
Medicaid or Medicaid products for kids
but we haven't separated a commercial
insurance link to STS versus medic stays
I would imagine if I was uh a betting
man that um certainly the Medicaid
population would have a larger link to
stay than the commercial
population but that's a little
presumptuous as well and then is the
prtf open it is open um I will say that
you know we have some EOC which an
environment of care challenges it's a
small unit sorry okay I've got a PR TF
and I've got a p and I need to know what
those are in words so I can write them
down just ask the AAL
that
world psych psychiatric Residential
Treatment
Facility uh EOC which I apologize is
environment of care so that's
essentially looking at your patient
rooms patient space area uh and making
sure that's safe thank you very much PF
one more time
psyri psychiatric Residential Treatment
Facility good no may you just built this
unit the prtf why would there be safety
issues in the rooms there are no safety
issues in terms of if you walk on the
unit is it a psychiatrically safe unit
it is uh when you look at the space that
that unit accompanies it's a smaller
unit so it can get a little crowded so
when you're dealing with patients who
may be a little bit more vibrant than
other patients there isn't a great place
to sort of separate those uh patients
that being said um off of that unit
which is a lot of the living space for
those residents they have classrooms
they have a family room um we are
looking at uh putting in laundry and
potentially a kitchen as more
experiential so kids can continue to do
their own laundry we can teach them how
to cook and reintegrate them back
outside of the residential piece so it
is a safe unit and we just want to
expand the realm of possibilities for
kids to move around and have different
spaces where they can decompress
throughout the day thank
you anyone else okay anything else from
the
commissioner I think that's it good
you and uh when you get your cards I'd
like one too I know there's a gap but
thank you and okay the chair recognizes
Carl ly I am SEI and I will accept
correction on that and I'm going to
probably do better with
Witman
yes and this is about a maternal
mortality
report and Dr Carolyn how do we
pronounce your last
from I spent a month in Nairobi several
much
so good morning can you hear me am I on
okay great um good morning um
chairperson
Pearson and members of the Health and
Human Services oversight committee hello
like we said my name is Carol whitmann
and I am the perinatal nurse and
maternal mortality review
coordinator with the Maternal Child and
health s Bureau um of family health and
nutrition
division of Public Health Services New
Hampshire
DHHS the function of the New Hampshire
mmrc has always been to conduct
comprehensive multi-disciplinary reviews
of maternal deaths to identify factors
associated with these deaths and to make
recommendations for future system
changes that improve the services for
the state's perinatal
population New Hampshire has completed
the fourth year of a 5-year CDC
enhancing reviews and surveillance to
eliminate maternal mortality which is
the eras mm
Grant um this was awarded from 2019 to
2024 uh this past year we have expanded
committee membership by including people
with lived experience and have utilized
subject matter experts that are able to
provide in-depth information about cases
so that the committee can make informed
determinations of pregnancy relatedness
preventability of the death and create
um concise
[Music]
recommendations thank you Carol for that
introduction so good morning I'm
Caroline yamas I'm the maternal and
child health epidemiologist at the
um at the maternal and child health
section Bureau of family health and
nutrition division of Public Health
services so i' like to start with um
just trying to let you know that we use
the identifying information on the New
Hampshire death certificate and birth
certificate records to identify maternal
deaths in New Hampshire the number of
deaths recorded each year has remained
consistent and so has the main leading
cause of death in calendar year 2022
there were eight maternal deaths five of
which died from substance use
[Music]
overdose so due to small numbers we
aggregated 5 years data that is from
2018 to 2022 to understand data Trends
and determine various maternal
characteristics associated with these
Debs about 53% of all pregnancy related
debts that occurred in the past 5 years
were caused by substance use overdose
opioids was was the leading cause
followed by cocaine and other
substances uh the second leading cause
of maternal deaths in New Hampshire is
cardiovascular related deaths such as
congestive heart failure hypertensive
cardiovascular disease cardiac arthia
and coronary heart diseases so most of
the deaths that occurred among women
aged 25 to 34 years old and about half
of the disident had acquired a high
school diploma or
so the mmrc committee determined that um
mental health condition were the leading
circumstances surrounding the overdose
deaths other social stresses present
were history of substance use treatment
psychiatric hospitalization or treatment
history of childhood trauma involvement
of child protective services and
unemployment so first we want to
acknowledge you all um for expanding
Medicaid in our state uh through one
year postpartum which we hope will
increase Behavioral Health Services
utilization since most overdose deaths
occurred postpartum that is 3 to to one
year and
56.5% of postpartum debts had their
delivery paid by
Medicaid this has been an early
recommendation of the mmrc and one that
has come up several
times lastly we've been working with the
division vital records and medical
examiner office to improve data quality
by ensuring the pregnancy check box
which which is on the death certificate
is failed there are circumstances
whereby we find null or unknown fails
and this will increase identification of
deaths occurring during pregnancy it's
impossible to identify women who are
pregnant but lost their pregnancy
earlier into into pregnancy except using
the pregnancy checkbox on the death
certificate therefore it is important
for the de certifier to verify history
of pregnancy by checking medical records
asking a family
member or a death informant when filling
the death
certificate uh this was also another MMC
recommendation I'll pass it to my
colleague
Carol so um due to the nature of
maternal deaths occurring in New
Hampshire uh work does continue on the
New Hampshire m RC recommendations that
improve the support and the care of the
perinatal population with substance use
disorder and mental health
conditions after the New Hampshire mmrc
reviews a case a multidisiplinary
subcommittee hones the recommendations
made during that meeting prior to their
implementation New Hampshire birthing
hospitals and perinatal providers are
accomplishing very important work
facilitating substance use screening and
referral during each trimester of
pregnancy as well as after delivery the
alliance for Innovation on maternal
Health which is aim their patient safety
bundles are a structured way of
improving the processes of care and
patient
outcomes New Hampshire is an aim
State directly because of an New
Hampshire MMC recommendation for its
support new this year additional grant
funding from the health resources and
services Administration to help
Implement safety bundles at all birthing
locations New Hampshire has also
received technical assistance from the
American College of O Obstetricians and
gynecologists um aims parent
organization patient safety bundles are
collections of evidence informed best
practices developed by
multi-disciplinary experts which address
clinically specific conditions in the
pregnant and postpartum
populations improving outcomes is their
goal a bundle includes actionable steps
that can be adapted to several um
various facilities and resource levels
um since 2020 all 16 of New Hampshire
birthing hospitals who are members of
the Dartmouth Health perinal quality
improvement Network maternal um maternal
and child health collaboration in both
the New Hampshire mmrc and aim
initiatives have been working on the
care of the pregnant postpartum people
with substance use disorder
bundle in October of
2023 the per perinatal mental health
conditions bundle rolled out here in New
Hampshire this bundle work includes
implementing screening for mental health
conditions during pregnancy after
delivery and making appropriate
referrals for services thank you very
questions yes Senator thank you um I see
that most of the de half the deaths were
due to drug
overdoses but when I look
at the next table seven it seems like
mental health conditions were as
important as substance use
disorder
conditions um but when I look at page 11
the followup actions I don't see
expansion of mental health treatment so
I'm wondering what let me just what your
thinking is or what you're
planning in addition to the substance
use
disorder expansion what are you doing
for mental health
so um when we are doing the reviews uh
first of all we have to identify the
immediate cause of death which is um
substance use disorder and when we are
filling the Maria committee forms
there's a question about circumstances
surrounding death and that's when we
look at the medical records and review
the case and we find that most of those
who had overdose had a mental health
condition or they were seeking um mental
health treatment so that's why table 7
has mental health conditions contributed
to death and this is for um out of the
21 dates that were reviewed between 2018
and
2022 uh your question regarding the
recommendations um on page 11 will be
best answered by my colleague uh because
um they're in charge of the
recommendations uh however just to add a
little bit that so finding out that
mental health condition was the leading
cause contributing factor it's like we
have to solve this underlying problem
that's why we uh beginning 2023 we
applied for a grant to start a patient
safety bundle which is on peral mental
health conditions and that bundle is
going to increase screening ear like
early screening treatment and
intervention for anyone with mental
health condition so that we can solve
this underlying problem I think my
colleague will want to add something on
the
same yes I just wanted to reiterate that
um we did in October roll out that
mental health safety bundle and that um
we we've had um successes with the
substance use disorder bundle and um and
we're looking to the Future um we were
working on that one for you know it was
since 20 2020 and that will still
continue on now we're adding to that the
mental health bundle and that will be
the expansion that we are working on I I
hope that answers your question thank
you representative
Merchant thank you and thank you for the
uh report by the way I looked on page 11
and it talks about recommendations from
the
mmrc the key says passed so does the
report in here somewhere I can't find it
maybe I'm seeing it but I don't
recognize it is there a recommendations
from this report is as far as going
forward because this is dealing with
what we have in the past so what are the
recommendations going
forward future
recommendations I'm sorry what page are
you on you on page 11 it references
2022 and I believe you are it says
followup actions from past New Hampshire
mmrc recommendations so what looking
forward what are the current ones going
forward that we're looking to work on or
to uh
put so the recommendations that were
10 and these recommend recommendations
came from all the cases that were
reviewed back in
20122 I'll need to approve my ey
glasses they sell them at pharmacies
okay representative Weber and so my
understanding is those recommend are
going ongoing now anding out into the
future so we don't have to find a whole
another separate category that is
correct it's very interesting how they
all build on each other I mean really
when you're um when you're working with
the trends um it's very clear that
substance use disorder and mental health
issues are are really the the primary
focus of what you know we need to
collaborativ be working
on so they tend to come up again and
again if I
representative I don't think you need to
convince anybody sitting at this table
that the two are completely
correlated representative McDonald thank
you Mr chairman um and thank you for
this report it's incredibly detailed and
and
comprehensive um table five um looking
at that find it very interesting on page
15 uh the highest number of deaths were
those living with a
relative and it seems like and and I'm
I'm sure that's accurate do you know
anything behind that because I would
think homeless the homeless number would
be higher for example than the someone
living with a relative and theoretically
having the support of family and so
forth
um apologies I was on a different table
five so I just noted you on the
appendices page 50 okay sorry about that
that's okay yeah so um so this
were I understand your concern about the
you believe the homeless should be
higher than this right however from the
cases we reviewed we found out that uh
very few owned like two of them owned a
house or owned their own space and the
three that we found were homeless we
just report what we see from the data
that that's what we pulled however most
of them lived with relatives so that
means probably they don't have their own
uh housing and that's why the number is
eight as compared to those who are
homeless but still um we believe that
the is accurate because we try to comb
all sources to just make sure that what
we are seeing in the records is what we
are presenting can I have a followup
followup uh so essentially the the eight
living with a relative is essentially
homeless that right yeah we we can say
that yeah because U majority were either
living with their mother or um just a
relative so definitely their income as
you saw in one of the tables
unemployment was another not actually
the tables on the what we read
unemployment was another stressor for
these um pregnancy related debts so
their income is low so definitely they
are living with a relative because
they're not able to sustain
themselves thank you you're
welcome Senator rosenal thank you on on
page
14 why is the
number of deaths from 2017 to 2022
different in table four than it is in
table
three yeah thank you for that question
and uh that's a wonderful um notice so
the number is supposed to be consistence
I guess I have to look one more time uh
why the totals are not 38 I thought they
should be 38 but I have to counter check
okay seeing no further questions
uh thank you Miss Whitman and Dr Nai for
coming before us in this report thank
you and I just noted it's the addition
that is the issue but it's the total st8
for table
four thank you very much thank you very
much
the chair now recognizes Mr Henry Lipman
you have a report to give you've asked
me if you could speak to other issues
and it looks like we have time at this
so
good morning for the record um Henry
lman the state Medicaid director I just
like to do one short introduction uh
David chne sitting behind me here is the
the deputy Medicaid director um if I'm
not available he's very um competent
capable Guy and um would be available as
a resource too as well would you give us
the name again please David David I got
that yeah chy c h o r NE y yeah yes got
it do you have cards business cards
could you dip into petty cash and get
him some business cards we can do
that I'll um I'll send the committee um
his contact information that's good
because it goes right here yeah um so
this the scheduled uh presentation was
uh a provision in hb2 of 2023 session
about uh the implementation of um the
postp partner coverage and what I
basically did in this report was pulled
language from the statute um and the the
first thing that we had to do was submit
a state plan by August 15 which we did
on August
14th um we did receive an approval um U
on November 2nd with a retroactive date
back to October 1st so coverage in New
Hampshire uh for postpartum began on
October 1st um and um it's a little bit
early for me to report out um uh
statistics on the implementation
components but we did Implement
according to the state plan all the the
different Provisions um I would expect
to on a uh quarterly basis give you some
update on um how the program is working
I think it will take a little while to
see um morbidity and mortality changes
but um I think we can at least start to
look at some access measures um
you know I think uh we had a a
three-hour meeting this week internally
with u the people who just presented
with you Medicaid and public health got
together to look at sort of
opportunities to to collaborate closer
um on on these issues and um I'm hoping
that we'll have some real results to to
show in terms of preventing um
conditions of complications and and
death um and uh the last last item that
we were was a little uh tucked away in
in that same section was a report on um
legislation that was passed uh in 2021
about opening up the maternal home
visiting programs and um what I've
included in the report at the end is
basically that we did um follow through
essentially what the legislation
intended to do was you know the 20101
period if you remember was a extreme
finan challenges for the state and
basically we reopened um the eligibility
um and then also clarified providers and
um other aspects that sort of modernized
the rule back in uh June of
2022 um I I don't have anything more
today on that if there's something of
particular interest um I could come back
with some utilization statistics or
something like that I just did not have
time I apologize to complete that before
today
I I would say that would be very helpful
she would say that would be very helpful
so would I we will'll do that for next
uh quarters report um the second thing I
wanted to uh come and talk to you about
was give you an update on the unwind um
and you know essentially um the first
page of your uh package at the the top
of the two lines of it gives you a
comparison of pre pandemic against post
pandemic we're as of uh the end of
179,180 th000 so end of month tends to
be a lower um enrollment number but
seems to be fluctuating between around
180 and 182 at this point in terms of
enrollment um also keep in mind that um
in addition to the postpartum coverage
that you passed you also uh passed um
for legally residing um uh individuals
women and children to be able to get
coverage that went into effect on um
January 1st also um federally all states
need to continuously enroll children for
a 12- month period and children is up
through up to uh through 18 years of age
um so that we we'll see I think over the
course of year some increase in
enrollment as a result of those
two things in addition I think the
system of care um part of hb2 um which
you may remember u in the Senate anyways
the Senate Bill 36 um that uh there were
some income disregards that were um
increased as a part of that legislation
and those went into effect January 1 so
we could see a little bit more
enrollment as a result of that um
another key thing because it was in the
news I just like to um speak to a couple
of slides here
um the second page um you know the CMS
had um identified New Hampshire along
with nine other states as having a
change in enrollment of children that
was um was larger um I think that that
report had a lot of uh flaws in it they
compared states that began in March
versus states that may have begun in
July and you know you would have
different outcomes but one of the things
want to share with you there's been a
you know a significant established Trend
long before the pandemic began of
decreased enrollment in children we see
that in school enrollments as well
um um that being said um I'm going to
speak to a little bit more what we have
done and what we did do as a result of
that um that that information coming
from
CMS um the third slide in you know is
another sort of reason why children and
enrollment might be less there are fewer
um children under 18 years of age um in
2022 compared to 2016 again that's
showing up in in our uh enrollment in
schools which I think you're down more
than 20,000 students um in terms of of
income New Hampshire has the fifth
highest enrollment excuse me fifth
highest eligibility level meaning it's
easier to enroll a child in um Medicaid
we go up to 32 % of the poverty the
national average is only 217% of poverty
so what we've seen is an increase in in
300% um and then also the next Slide the
fist slide in um there are uh people
with U 400% of income I guess that's
basically we as we've seen the New
Hampshire economy has bounce back after
um sort of the the two 2020 21 2020
impact of of being unwind so then on the
sixth slide is a a table actually I
prepared for CMS to sort of give them
some feedback on what we're actually
seeing and when they looked at children
they they looked at it differently than
we had been um they looked at it as
anyone 23 years of age or younger and so
um the reason they did that is because
certain kids like Foster children could
still have coverage so okay now that
we're both looking at the same group of
of children so what we did is we pull
together an analysis here of children
who on March 1st of
2023 um were on Medicaid and looked at
what the outcomes of those children were
and we divided that between protected
and nonprotected uh children and so that
um with respect to um the the size of
these two groups the protected group if
you look at the bottom of that slide was
36,24120
of that larger Group which is sort of
the middle column um only 133% did not
retain coverage compared to the
projected Group which is on the left
which was um a little over 50% 50 uh
51.1% retain coverage
um some of them remained in as
children's coverage small percentage 3.2
ended up in granted Advantage uh 0 4%
and other 3% and then in and out um but
if you look at the reasons why they
closed in that First Column um income
47% closed because of income there's not
much we can do if you're over 323 per of
poverty there's not much we can do with
that um failing to complete a
redetermination um that that was
28.5% again we've done amazing amount of
Outreach um and what we've done in terms
of this failed to read group and the
fail to verify group we've actually done
um most recently and are about to
complete we've called every single one
of those individuals again um and and an
effort from the department and the mcos
we've also built reports with the for
the fqhcs C mhc's because this is a a
fixed population we're able to identify
them and and provide information we're
working to make sure that they have
every opportunity to try to come back on
either to complete their redetermination
or not but when you look at you know why
kids were
disenrolled um you know failed to reduce
a concerning number but it it sometimes
it can be because the family doesn't
feel like they're eligible um and we've
certainly gone round after round of
trying trying to do Outreach there but
you know that being said we are making
one more um good try effort to try to uh
reach all these folks and remember
Medicaid is a continuously open program
so if they um change um the other thing
that would be interesting to note we
don't really have good insight into it
yet but New Hampshire's um exchange
coverage the ACA coverage that we've
seen a 19% growth according to The
Navigators and a call I had with them
this morning um and that doesn't also
measure um some families that may have
gotten off exchange coverage um meaning
they didn't qualify for any subsidies so
I think we are seeing some people
getting coverage elsewhere you can see a
little bit of that in in this data as
well um so that's what I have on that
slide
um then um have uh a couple of different
sort of uh picture graphs that have
different information about where we are
with the unwind the first one on slides
the seventh slide in um shows that there
300 if you look on the far right the top
how many red determinations are left to
do um of the nearly 104,000 we have 350
left as of the end of December um we're
taking our time as as much as we can
we're actually going out to May for for
those who are like the Homing community
base to make sure that we have enough
bandwidth to help them we're finding
that particularly the people in um
homebound have the most challenge in
completing the process so we've ex we've
taken advantage of a number of
flexibilities including extending the
period of time to accomplish
that um in the bottom left I won't go
over all this chart but you can see that
um there are summary statistics for
closure reasons income is the number one
reason that um
that the protected population
closed um and there's a chart on
children um children was the number one
reason on the bottom left was failed to
redetermined very closely by by
income um in this case again I think
that one of our early campaigns back in
May was when we heard that National
stories about parents um if they were
not eligible thinking that their child
could be eligible we did a round of
phone calls then to make sure that um
all of the the individuals were who had
clothes with children that they were
aware that there was an opportunity to
keep the kids covered and and we're
doing that as part of our our current
Outreach um the next slide uh is the
long-term care and disabled population
most you can see from this slide on the
top right um the future redeterminations
that's the majority of people that are
left to redetermining the long-term care
and disabled
group um income is the number one reason
follow closely behind failed to
redetermined again we're doing um doing
continued Outreach uh to this population
um so the next slide slide 10 is really
an interesting slide to me in terms of
um exp part rates expart means that the
department has enough information um
based on what access that we have to
various sources that we can determine
that they're eligible um you can see a
significant increase in the expart rate
as we go further into the unwind in part
that's because we left people who
expected to be covered to later in the
unwind um and so in terms of this has
been something that the feds have
focused on in terms of state's
performance and I think we're you know
standing out pretty well there and
um uh the next slide is uh a look at
when we're looking at this the monthly
statistics which are coming up in the
chart there are some people we don't
complete in a month this is something
CMS has asked states to do is to look
back 90 days did anybody who didn't
redetermined um by the end of their
month did they later come back on and
you can see in the orange that um people
who didn't complete and you can see
month by month um that people do come
back on even if they don't if they're
shown as not renewing in in the current
month um you know August has a bigger uh
set of numbers and that's part when we
implemented an extra 60 days for the
disabled U and waiver populations and
long-term care so that you would expect
the pending to be larger because because
we're giving them more
time um if I can jump down to the um the
next slide
um you know throughout the unwind these
are statistics that that tie to what we
report to the federal government that
um uh the if you look at sort of the
flesh tone color line that's the the
percent of people that retain coverage
um the grand total
and then divided by the protected and
nonprotected but if you jump down to the
slide that follows and look at a more
recent month um and look at that plush
tone line 91.3% of the the non-protected
population retain coverage and 54.7 of
the protected again I think that
reflects our unwind strategy of the
people that we thought were most likely
to retain coverage would and if you if
we if I had all the slides in here and I
didn't want to bury you in slides
because I have given you enough but if
you went back all the way to September
you start to see the real shift in the
number of people um retaining coverage
and you also see that in that graph of
exp parte uh renewals and
um the next slide is just about
reopenings people if they're going to
reopen they're typically doing that
within a 90-day window um and the final
slide is just some of our call campaign
activity that's done
the most concerned patients we have for
by looking at Medical claims we have our
medical team do outbound calls and what
we're finding is a lot the most the
majority of people are it's not that
they're not aware that it's just taking
them time to complete their
redetermination you know 50 almost 54%
are aware they're in process and by the
time we get to them about 30 and a half
percent are already um completed that's
spoken a lot and thrown a lot at you but
I hope uh you get a general sense at
least from the conversation here that
you know we're doing better as we go
along as expected and we're we're pretty
close to being finished with the the
unwind um population representative
Weber I'm sorry I I'm I'm feeling like
the days in law school where I was
required to confess to the professor
when I came to class unprepared and I
did come to class
unprepared uh although you sent out a
lot of this material beforehand and
because I am scribbling with my right
hand I can't also flip the charts with
my left
hand could you back up one step and
explain to me again about protected and
unprotected classes because I would have
thought just without looking at anything
that a the protected class would be the
ones that have the highest retention
rates and it it's backwards every time
you mention those categories so I need a
reeducation it is counterintuitive for
people who were protected were probably
back in March of 2020 um were were
covered by Medicaid and three years or
longer they haven't had to reup whether
they're eligible or not and so you know
in March of 2020 there was a whole lot
of people that came on board because
they lost their jobs as a result of the
pandemic so people you know the economy
has gotten better people have come back
to work and so forth or they aged out of
their you know being out in a category
that's eligible so like for example in
graned Advantage we had people who were
you know it's that's a great program for
people who are older adults who may lose
a job later in life now they're Medicare
eligible so they left the program
because they're Medicare eligible so we
expected all along that about the
percentage that we're seeing in the
protected group would would leave
because of various reasons like
that thank you you're welcome
representative
Merchant thank you El I wanted to thank
you as always the information you
provide to this committee is incredibly
detailed very thorough and I want to
recognize that thank you in regards to
one of the things you mentioned that
sort of caught my attention it's a
little bit of a on page 50
it goes back into the yellow unaware
child income difference and you sort of
talked about that before where the
parents' income and the children's
income if they're in the same household
how are they different because there
really is one source of income it's the
parents so the eligibility criteria if
you're for example in the granted
Advantage the Medicaid expansion your
income is 138% so if you're at
150% you don't qualify for for medic
Medicade but if your if your household
is below
323 the CH children still
would so so I can I think I understand
it want to be sure so basically there's
different levels depending upon whether
you're an adult or child yes or whether
you're a waiver there's you know there's
a page too big for me to memorize of
different categories but generally what
it it comes down to is that you know the
program tilts in favor of children
remaining covered terms of the
eligibility levels of the highest thank
you I have a couple of questions on
pages seven eight and N maybe more on
the left side you have a wonderful map
of New Hampshire and I love well I love
New Hampshire too but I love maps and I
think the reason Rockingham County is
always in dark blue is because we have
310,000 people yes might the same kind
of data be presented with maps where the
number the raw number is as a percentage
of the population of the state I I do
have those I bet you do we um we just
again just trying to I'm not I could
bury you in in charts and crafts and
stuff but bring it on
okay my second question is I have a few
friends yes who believe prolife is from
birth and we expanded one month after
birth to 12 and for the sake of any of
my aforementioned friends whom I listen
to me I would love to have numbers and
especially Narrative of how that
expansion from one month to 12 months
has done good both from a human
compassion point of view but also
perhaps even from a financial point of
view which is the metric that some
people only focus on so I just want to
make sure I understand your question
your referring to the I just want I'm
not sure I picked up on it well we
passed something you referenced it yes
that oh the the coverage of uh
postpartum extension yes okay now I got
you I just want that for me would be a
very helpful apologetic to people who
are still not convinced yeah I I think
that probably of of um among the thing
top things that I think will affect
people in real real way is that coverage
the adult dental coverage because I
think in the postpartum coverage if you
think about um particularly sud mental
illness um you know postpartum
depression you know to try to get access
even if you have the best insurance in
the state to to try to get everything
done within you know um 60 days of of
birth it's just it's it's unrealistic
and so that's I think um you know one of
the things I think we're going to look
at is what difference does this this
make and I think you know along with my
back here we yes yeah see I get it from
having been in the people business for
50 years but for those who really do
need convincing and might either be
convinced by the H humanitarianism of it
or just the dollar and cense of it uh
that would be helpful follow up after
this has happened for a while I I I
agree oh okay representative
McDonald thank you Mr chairman um Mr
Litman could you and I know you already
did but if you if you're good to repeat
it what is the definition of expar in
this case sure it's when we have enough
information um for
example granted Advantage is probably
the easiest one that's an income
eligible program um we get feeds of of
of individuals income if they're not
self-employed as an example um and so if
we know what their income is um and they
we're required under law to work with
the information we have and and that's
what it means is that we have all the
information we need to know to know that
this person is eligible and so we don't
make them complete paperwork that is
something we already know about I just
follow up uh so in other words um just
to clarify they don't have to go through
the reading process you they don't have
to fill out an application any of that
stuff right you already have what you
have you need yeah so I give you a good
example of something that I've you know
and going through the NWI one of the
things I've noticed is that particularly
the granted something I hadn't thought
about until going through this process
and looking at the churn that happens
sometimes is that
um that people who are are disabled you
takes a while to prove your disability
um and so granted Advantage sometimes
becomes a very uh important bridge to at
least having medical coverage until that
disability may be determined so like a
case like that where someone it may take
six months or a year sometimes to get
through that process um that you know
someone who we know is unemployed still
because of their
disability they have no income rather
than making them go through all that
paperwork of doing a redetermination we
have enough information to to to let
them know we've seen what your situation
is and we're extending you for the
period of time and you're required to
let us know of a change in circumstance
but your your eligibility continues one
more follow one more followup um okay
and and that's that makes a lot of sense
um is there any question about whether
you might not have the most accurate
information and maybe some people might
slip by who aren't eligible is there any
concerns about that um I think that
there there always is some risk of of
that but I I think it's probably pretty
minuscule I mean I think um you know in
one sense we're kind of we do required
under we could get penalized the other
way for for for you know ruling people
out based on information we do have so
it's kind of like if you will the grand
bargain with the the feds in terms of
they're giving us 90% example and that
we're going to follow their regulation
um okay thank you Senator Rosenwald
thank you morning Henry um my question
is about children with
disabilities I see on page one that the
rate the current number is down 18%
versus prepandemic
but the decline in the number of
children in state is closer to 4%
so what's up so we did we did get that
question from one of the executive
councils a little while ago and did uh
look into that issue and um most of it
was aging out
um um and um so we didn't see anything
and I can um follow up with the analysis
that we did uh Senator to give you some
comfort there um but certainly
the the K the children I worry about
Katy Becket uh type cases and things
like that that um you sometimes that
journey of particularly like cases where
they now have got gone over 18 years of
age they're still a child in the eyes of
the the parent right they're 19 or 20
there's some things that happen there um
and just going through the process it's
it's not easy to do and so um again
again that's why I think we're trying to
give more time in the process to work
there and and when you know there have
been some cases I always encourage you
if you hear of a situation to to bring
it to me because they're small enough
that you know we can provide individual
attention to see what's going on there
um we've met recently as as early as
this week with um a provider that
provides a lot of support to
individuals um who are sort of Katy Beck
eligible and making sure she understood
what the criteria are and you know said
created an Open Door one of the state
senators had connected her to us so
that's the kind of stuff we appreciate
because if something's not going the way
it should from we'd like to know about
it maybe it is because it isn't or or
maybe it's there's something we could do
to
help follow so so it doesn't mean that
more children are being born without
disabilities no I think it's more that
there's less children and less children
that may meet the income qualifications
approved but I'd be happy to follow up
thank anything further for Mr Lipman I
notice Mr chy is taking great mental
notes
Here do you have a business card
yet
yeah anybody else um had a quick one on
Dental if you were um I provided three
slides there if you have time we're
going to give in the schedule I think we
will so let's uh let's get our I'm going
to say it let's get our teeth into this
one you knew it's coming knew you knew
that was coming you already wrote it in
the
minutes
um the second second slide is um the
number of
encounters um both in claims and in um
individual people uh seen and as you
look at the later months you see a a
little bit of a decline there part of
that is the time frame to submit claims
December
also because um you know pra physician
practices may not maintain the same
schedule over the holidays um but you
can see generally the trend has been in
a positive direction um that you know
for more months than than not more than
2,000 adults have been seen um and that
you know we've had a high of 3,000
individual claims um in the month of
November
um and uh the third slide in is the
unique providers I think that we're up
to 158 now
um and uh I I had hoped I was supposed
to get this morning and it may be in my
email was the I think the last time I
presented to you was in the 120
neighborhood um so we have made some
slow and steady progress in in building
out the network
um and where we're not building out the
network um the last slide is you know
we're still um utilizing mobile clinics
that are not schedule for uh the rest of
January and February is up here on the
on that slide um Dr finny's away so this
week so I didn't have a chance to to do
as much here as I'd like either but um
next time that you have time for me I'd
be happy to Dr Finny to to elaborate a
little bit more there was I think
U recently um CMS published on their uh
dashboard of
um public information
about um uh different children's
indicators and and one of them was um
connected to U applying sealant and in
both situations in the Children's Dental
we were well above the national average
in in that which um you know I think
uh says a lot um in terms of what we've
been able to do now that we've had the
been able to fund through hb2 the rate
increase to match up Children's Dental
with adult Dental I think will continue
to make progress
there having grown up in lemonster it
does my heart good to see that at least
in this Worcester County is now part of
New
Hampshire yes sir um could you speak and
you know this is a question I bring up a
lot uh any status report on incentive
programs for new dentist s to
participate in this especially new
dentists with lots of dchool loans
outstanding any update you can give us
we do um and I think still here um in
terms of loan repayment program um we do
have a couple of dentists coming up for
uh receiving loans um in that space and
I think even some of the hygienists as
well um so I think you know it's
important to have both pieces to to have
a practice so I think there's been more
activity there um and I think probably
Sarah could add some more Dimensions to
that than I than I am able to today if
next time she or you are here and
speaking on this a one-pager you know
half a page with numbers and graphs and
so on and a half a page in narrative
would be very helpful for me because
this is a selling point I try to use
with some folks so one thing Delta has
done on the um you know they had the
thousand sign on bonus which they
extended and extended I'm not sure
whether they still extended it but I can
find out have their address of when that
may have come to a close or if it has
the second thing is that um you know
where they have received feedback from
practicing dentists about the fee
schedule Delta out of their own um
medical cost and are or dental cost
rather are um enhanced the New Hampshire
Fe scheduled to try to deal with
procedures where dentists felt there may
still be an undervalue um and um she can
give you more details on that as well
representative
Merchant
you a question for you in regards to on
the third page it's svin County it has
two contracted dentist it's encouraging
to see that in windso which is adjacent
to the county of Sullivan in the vont
side has eight but when I go to the last
page and I look at what's available for
the mobile D downal Clinic I don't see
svin County on there I I know that um an
Landry who's my associate commissioner
made that point to me too before and I
know one of the issues there has been
finding a site to site it um I know that
based on a couple meetings ago that
that's a priority I don't know whether
in before this whether they actually
made it there or not and I can get back
to or not but I know s was on our radar
to to get there for just the reason you
talked
about follow
up in regards to a site within Sullivan
County what's involved
to require a site um I'd be more than
glad to try to make some calls inquir
with people within the county for a site
if I understand what's required yeah um
I I probably can have Sarah do that but
the the major thing we see is that this
is a a very big vehicle um in terms of
and then being able to get the um I
guess the connections there but um Sarah
has all those details and I know she's
been working on it because it it came up
previously and and my boss and told me
she wants to Z that too so I'll follow
I'll follow up with you upline thank you
yeah well thank you Mr Litman as always
and uh please send uh uh Mr ch's contact
information uh in L of card thank you
we'll we'll work on I know rating Petty
you public awareness campaign on brain
health Alzheimer's disease related
dementias quarterly report Wendy Alman
escalent and
uh the committee is a subcommittee of
this committee so we get you in both
ways so thank you yes um good morning uh
thank you uh representative U Senator
Pearson uh I'd like to start by talking
a little bit about the update that we
sent to you um in October we provided an
overview of our plan um related to the
Alzheimer's disease and related dementia
public awareness campaign so I've
provided some updates within this
document and I'd like to just focus um
on those and then Jessica would like to
talk a little bit about the the
subcommittee uh on page two of the plan
um I'd like to just give an update on
where we're at today um in terms of
progress we've completed uh coming to
the committee talking about our plan and
partnering with others to develop a
request for proposals um that has been
released and we are currently in the
procurement process so uh there may be
questions that I may not be able to
fully answer because we're still in that
procurement process but I did provide a
link um within the report to our uh
procurement page which has uh all of the
documents related to this procurement on
it as well as the questions and answers
that potential um applicants have sent
into us and that we've replied to um
that may help with providing a little
bit of an update on um interest in uh
sending in a proposal and the closing
date of proposals was this week and um
we will have a competitive process um uh
and we're scheduled in early February um
to have a team of people reviewing
proposals and then we'll move forward
contract seems like no questions keep on
keeping on all right thank you thank
you Jessica escalin good morning Mr
chair members of the committee Jessica
esand with the Alzheimer's Association
uh please to share that the subcommittee
on Alzheimer's and other dementia which
is the chair mentioned is a subcommittee
of this committee uh has met twice so
far and is due to have its first meeting
of 2024 next Wednesday the
31st um and it has had robust uh
involvement by membership it the
membership is a bunch of
multi-disciplinary folks bringing lots
of expertise in various areas to the
table and looking at uh the various
charges of the subcommittee as La as
laid out in the enabling
legislation um getting input soliciting
um presentations from various folks in
different Industries and representatives
of uh sort of the the spectrum of people
engaging with this disease um up to an
including getting input from folks
living with this disease and what their
experience is in the State uh so again
we're early in our work Wednesday will
be our third meeting but so far so good
where will you be meeting and when um
room 103 of the State House at 3 pm on
Wednesday and I'm happy to um forward
that notice to the members thank you
could you also Supply us a list
with each member where that member is
coming from it's an appointment of this
or that or the other thing and any
contact information that would help
those of us in the committee uh to know
a little bit more about the subcommittee
absolutely happy to thank
you where do you see your next work as a
subcommittee where's your focus next
sure so on Wednesday we're getting a
presentation um from someone from the
association who does our regional
manager who does education and Outreach
to sort of level set the knowledge base
of the subcommittee again everyone is
coming from a different perspective uh
looking at it through a different lens
so really talking sort of Alzheimer's
and Dementia 101 uh the Baseline in
terms of where we're at a snapshot in
the state and trends that we're seeing
and then perspectively the uh subsequent
presentation in February would be um
from a geriatrician who is providing
care in the state and so the the
clinical view that they're seeing and so
what we're really trying to do is based
on the charges set out statuto for the
subcommittee uh solicit information and
input and presentations from those
various entities to inform our work and
ultimately as required in the statute to
update the state uh plan on
Alzheimer's let me put a little push
since um it is Alzheimer's and other
types of dementia Max languished for a
number of years with parkinsonia
dementia which presents very similarly
but it's a little different and just
don't want that sub category to be
ignored no absolutely not and I didn't
mean to imply that you didn't I and I
didn't even infer it's just got that
applying for um I just wanted to bring
it up thank you yes absolutely I'm so
sorry for that no I'm fine any questions
thoughts you know if you don't say more
Mr litman's gonna come back for 26
minutes
[Laughter]
so yes please I don't think any
anybody's going to object to us actually
ending early which we never do so I just
wanted to note that but I also want to
express my thanks to everybody as one
who spent last week being a
you associate commissioner Tilly
anything congratulations on your
promotion thank
you anyone else with standing to come
before the committee
seeing
none yes go
ahead we do have a quorum we can vote on
you chair will entertain a motion on
last meeting's minutes I'll make a
motion to approve the minutes from the
last meeting so moved a second second
representative McDonald any discussion
all in favor I poos
the minutes are
accepted Oh by 4 to zero oh but you are
here for cor of purpose but she can vote
to abstain yep because she wasn't here
and she thought and she operates under
Senate
yes and some of us who just sort of you
know make it up okay with that this uh
you